francis lalanne à la gare de saint rémy
les chevreuse
hier soir le chanteur co-président du
mouvement 100% et de l'alliance
écologiste indépendante est venu parler
de son combat pour une écologie au
centre de tout quelques tracts
distribués à des voyageurs pressés et
pas de candidats du département présents
avec lui et cela ne l'a pas découragée a
présenté sa vision de la société la
protection la défense de la nature et le
respect du vivant et d engagement
citoyen dont la 12e' à petit roeulx on a
par exemple de ne programmer ce qu'on
appelle les systèmes d'échangés locaux
les selles ou justement vous avez un
appareil photo qui vous sert plus aux en
voulait plus quelqu'un d'autre un
aspirateur dont vous avez besoin bail
il faut qu'ils soient informés que vous
ayez que les lui il a besoin d'un
appareil photo il faut qu'ils soient
informés que vous avez cet appareil
photo vous allez changer etc
on a aussi par le mit en place talent la
banque du temps la banque du temps vous
par exemple dans la journée vous avez du
temps que vous pourriez consacré aux
autres il faut que les autres le sache
pour qu'ils puissent vous sollicitez